[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades today we continue into the
world of myths and folklore in bot night
chapter 2 because you and I my friend
are myths jaysis if you have a myth
you'd like us to test out write it down
in the comments below it can be serious
or it can be completely ridiculous we
have a few ridiculous ones today so if
you've slapped code a tomorrow in the
item shop and eaten all your Halloween
haul let's do this as Halloween has just
passed let's look at a few myths brought
to us by the undead starting with that
central island here's our first myth
from epic and bacon
who says can you get zombies in a boat
and drive them around straight off the
battle bus and let's go down and grab a
boat let's see if we can get a husk on
this speedboat the first plan was to
drop one of the undead onto the boat
using a ramp from above but these husks
are trained to brake ramps instead of
climb them it took us a little time but
our next plant looks promising to phase
the boat under the tile in the river and
then when a zombie got close enough
we'd edit or destroy the title and check
this out the zombie is now on the boats
yes he's technically donkey punching me
in the back of the head but at the
moment he's dead so now it's time for
the moment of truth can we take this bad
boy for a ride go go go no damn No we
tried this a few times but sadly the
zombies can only hover above the boat
and when the boat finally moves away
those zombie touches the water and then
they go back to being dead again Oh
Undead you know you know what I mean
anyway myth busted no stick it with
those freaks the next myth is from pika
hero 12 who asks can you get a zombie
off the island well mission accepted my
friend so the boat failed but what about
a bridge let's do this it looks done
promising is it possible will they get
all the way to the other side or will
there be an invisible barrier which
kills them before they reach it to the
other side
[Music]
Wow who dafuq that the zombies are no
longer stranded so we took them for a
day out around the town
[Music]
whilst Alton about I was able to try out
three more myths what happens when an
island husk meets a soccer zombie will
they fight our team up well let's check
it out they team up and attack players
pretty cool combo next what happens when
a husk walks into a campfire are you
ready for this epic gamer moment well
it's like luster as hell they're zombies
walk straight through it like it isn't
even there rip the dream and during our
day away with Harry the husk we met two
more zombie soccer players perfect time
to test another myth what happens when a
soccer zombie touches water a simple
test my friends this happens they don't
even need to get close to most rivers
they explode from sheer excitement oh
that day with Harry was epic we
frolicked all game and died in each
other's arms you will never be forgotten
Harry does it was a lovely day okay back
to the myths here's one I wanted to test
out what happens when a pumpkin launch a
rocket hits another pumpkin launch a
rocket let's try this here we go and oh
well that's anticlimactic the Rockets
completely ignore one another and phase
through so we took this myth to the next
level what happens when to play is
rocket right into each other a simple
test which took us far far too long
course we're a bunch of boss but the
replay theater doesn't help either
because it glitches out but here it is
as the two rockets hit one another the
players are simply pushed aside and
simply fall off the Rockets so all that
hard work or pretty much nothing but you
gotta admit it looks badass watching
someone rocket right on a damn pumpkin
while we are here we can test one more
myth this comes from Jamie xx who says
is it possible to rocket right and jump
to another rocket so he wants us to
stand on one rocket an attempt to get on
another one right seems pretty hard but
luckily before we even tried this myth
this happened whilst rocket riding
towards another rocket
somehow the second rocket to control the
situation check it it's confusing isn't
it but technically myth confirmed but
now I challenge you guys can you attempt
to do this better than us
double rocket ride start on one rocket
and jump to another if you manage this
please upload a video to YouTube and DM
me on twitter my handle is atom grenade
and my DMS are always open last week I
asked you to try to myths the first was
to climb all the way to the top of yeet
Mountain in a boat and all my word you
guys absolutely bought this so many of
you replied with texts and screenshots
but here's a group of leggins who
uploaded a clip to youtube you guys are
officially grenade myth chasers
I'm going to look into getting some
enamel badges made for people who myth
chase with us a badge to represent you
are a myth chaser I could be good I'll
look into it I'm getting sidetracked
sorry back to it the second myth I asked
you to check out is if you could throw a
downed player onto a rocket I thought it
was impossible but check this out damn
impressive
well played the last person I saw rocket
ride that well was now we have a super
secret myth from a highly reputable
source this is going to be difficult
this is going to be game-changing for
everyone
are you ready a guy called Adam arrow
writes this is it possible to high-five
a person's but what a great question
after tomorrow we will try this for you
so to do this we need to have the
unlocked emote in the battle path we
then dropped into a custom game and
found an enemy two down then the moment
of truth came can we use a two person
emote whilst carrying a downed enemy and
check this
this is beautiful this is perfection
this is game-changing the only thing
which could make this better are thick
skins so epic games we demand that penny
is released from the bunker now we wait
patiently for your response okay I'll
move on from sick penny I apologize
while trying this myth we decided to try
out this one from what the hell name is
that xxx amok sex sex
what kind of a name is that okay
Internet Zemo asks can we eat whilst on
a zipline great question to the zipline
do we go and here it is myth confirmed
[Music]
now these are good myths GG community we
are on a roll let's go on to the next
one please
strike Corvis writes myth can a Supply
Drop land on a boat good question my
dude let's test this if it can then we
can have movable cover and extra mats
and supplies on demand this could be
huge here's my first attempt at catching
a Supply Drop as you can see I'm a
complete idiot
don't worry though attempt number two
went far better
[Music]
myth confirmed we've done it the pallet
has vanished which represents a
successful drop so let's take this cube
for a spin ah damn it sadly this is a
fail just like the husks earlier the
Supply Drop only hovers above the boat
until it moves out of the way so sorry
strike Corvis we let you down
okay next myth have you seen the video
of the player dolphin diving from the
highest waterfall and falling to their
death there's actually a little Easter
egg on the map right now you can look at
it but we'll cover that in the next map
update video so that led me to thinking
can you survive a dolphin dive from the
highest point onto hard ground I know
what you're thinking Adam you're insane
you've lost your mind well to you I say
hold my beer
[Music]
[Music]
myth confirmed ladies you can indeed
survive a leap of faith from a waterfall
onto hard ground the physics on this one
are literally hit and miss but it looks
like the timing of your jump is
imperative just as you're leaving the
waterfall hit jump and that's the key to
survival it works both from a standing
jump and a mid-air dolphin dive too you
can literally roll through and remain
unhurt epic gamer moments if that
doesn't make this video deserver like I
don't know what will
and the little housekeeping from last
week I said it was not possible to
rocket ride a boat missiles and
challenged you to prove me wrong
and you did prove me wrong here's a few
examples of Awesomeness also I've tried
this again since and I still cannot do
this but the evidence is out there so I
admit defeat and one other thing I said
it was possible to emote on zip lines
you all agreed but I said it wasn't
possible for all emotes to be used and
once again you proved me wrong the trick
is get close enough to trigger the
zipline but before you activate start
your emote GG's on that one fellow myth
chases I have no problem with admitting
when I'm wrong so thank you very much
okay I think we've done enough myth
chasing this week thanks for your time
and throw your myths in the comments
below and if you're on my discord I'll
call on you to help me myth busting myth
confirm in future weeks oh and if you're
wondering why I've changed the name of
this series it's pretty simple you guys
told me in my first episode that I'm not
as original as I thought I was so I did
some research and you're right there's
at least six channels that have done
myth busting way before me so I've
decided to distance myself from those
people and change the name so we are
myth chasers from now on I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
thanks for your time see you soon
[Music]